brennan how do you know when you're
actually
in ketosis it's it's a it's a guessing
game if you do the keto diet if you're a
keto kid
if you're a kido kid how do you know
when you're in ketosis you don't have to
guess anymore bro because there's keto
i'm talking key
k-e-y-t-o keto breath sensor is the most
accurate
and easy way to measure your level of
ketosis and get real-time personalized
feedback on your diet via an
app it's like a breathalyzer yeah man
will help you lose weight improve your
health and feel
better this app features key eats
program
it's a straightforward food guy for
recipe resources focus on healthy fats
okay from fish to plant-based sources
because a lot of people do keto and
they're doing it the wrong way they're
doing
pounds of bacon they're eating sauce
just because it's keto that means you're
healthy
you'll send your your triglycerides and
your your ldls
through the roots yeah sure man you guys
can do this by going to
[Music]
getketo.com fighter
g-e-t-k-e-y-t-o dot com slash fighter
yes man the website's get keto dot com
slash fighter
keto breath sensors keto premium
subscription are available at get keto
dot com
slash fighter the keto app is available
on your android
on your iphone um it retails for 99
provides keto level readings as well as
access to key food products
with the app for only eight dollars a
month you can upgrade a keto premium for
access to videos articles recipes
this is big restaurant guides all right
because when you get to restaurant
you can kind of guess what's keto or you
can use the exact science
there might be no better diet for losing
weight yeah i dig it man i feel great on
it
20 off your first purchase go to kee get
keto dot com
slash fighter and our promo code fighter
for 20
off your first purchase get shredded
brandon talk to me about whoop you want
me to whoop it up
look i want to here's the thing bro
yesterday went on a hike yeah
i'm using this app on my phone tells me
like the the
how far i'm going right it says six mile
hike yeah i throw on that whoop
i throw on that whoopty whoop wait wait
wait because i throw on that whoop
yeah it was actually seven and a half
miles so
it's in a lot of ways the most accurate
wristband hold on it's the only
wristband you should have
rocking because it monitors your heart
rate 24 7 over a hundred times a
second so you know the technology is
better than uh
way better there's nothing like it
there's nothing like it also if you're
working out like crazy
you know what's more important than your
workouts recovery yeah your recovery is
so damn important
how hard you strain it they're going to
tell you they let me know exactly on my
hikes when i'm working out at home
how does it teach you actually that
you're getting like rem sleep
sleep all that to the highest level
whoop provides insights that others just
don't
not this level not at this precise
level you can tell if you have sleep
apnea if you're waking up all the time
your heart rate everything maybe not
feeling well
maybe you shouldn't do that seven mile
hike today because you're not fully
recovered
maybe you didn't get the sleepy thought
maybe save for the next day yeah when
your whoop tells you you're ready to go
dude that's a huge part of
not getting it serious i'm telling you
it's a game changer it's a life changer
the battery
days they get lasts new 3.0 strap you
guys get 30
off that's right you get 30 off go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com use the code fighter at checkout
to save 30
and optimize the way you train fighter
for 30 years fighter for 30
off whoop membership get you some i'll
tell you something right now it's [ __ ]
rock monday
yeah it's [ __ ] rock monday yeah man it
is and i know you're fresh off denver
i'm fresh off tampa
yeah here's the thing about tampa and
ybor city and i want to shout out to
everybody because
when you go when you're on seventh
avenue there or maybe it's 7th street
who gives a [ __ ]
but it's ybor city there's something
about that strip where people on a
saturday and a friday night will get in
there
in their trucks and they have speakers
that are about
they're as wide as the the widest dish
and they want you to know that they they
like that
they blast that music so it's
and they that's what they're doing hurt
your little old ears hurts my little
ears but then there's a guy behind him
on a motorcycle with even louder
speakers on the motorcycle
it sure is it's they're [ __ ] why do
you think they do it though because they
they don't read no or it has to be an
eagle thing because like the guy on the
motorcycle like already your motorcycle
is loud enough yeah but then the
the stereo is blasted so high let's do
that 19 so you know they can do
bluetooth radio from there to your
helmet yeah so we all don't have to
listen to your board yeah but no they
that's like listen this these are my
speakers
they're literally rolling they got rims
and they're rolling through to show you
their rims and how loud their music is
but
i saw this one couple these two they
were like a biker couple
and this dude had like kind of long hair
she had some tits on them she had she
was just heavy
she's on the back big old yeah yeah the
big hungry
they were probably 47. [ __ ] yeah and
they were doing it they were roadhogs
yup and then and then it's just so
interesting it's just like this
it's kind of a combination of redneck
ghetto
it's all this like it it was incredible
it's a it's a weird it's
weird i one guy rolled up on the buy on
his [ __ ] harley
and he had a uh this is like two weeks
ago in la which is super ballsy to do
he had on uh american flag bandana
backwards
[ __ ] bullies i haven't seen him
forever sleeveless shirt
and then the music was kid rock going my
name is king
rock boom we just had a red light and i
was feeling it though damn
that's a little jealous but that's a guy
who's like just so you guys know i'm
here and i [ __ ] i look down
oh that guy [ __ ] dudes no i like you
should always do that you should go bro
you [ __ ] well i just wanna i know you
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
yep and then you go like this you go you
point and you give him the thumb
he doesn't hear anything he can't see or
he can't hear it doesn't matter
say it anyway to him in his direction
dude you uh no you look at the car next
to you and you go hey this guy
[ __ ] like you're like this this guy
[ __ ] got [ __ ] up
the moon roof then you go
congratulations dude number one on your
speakers on the choices you're making
on [ __ ] going song sleeves
songs is french with without you're
going saw
sleeves i mean you're amazing bro you're
a hater on those guys dude
one catches you and [ __ ] you
on the back of his harley oh [ __ ] dude
you missed uh you were missed in denver
man
i haven't been there in a hot second
it's one of the best clubs ever
i would say besides the seller right and
then the comedy store
it's probably the third i'm third most
famous club yeah
right yes i think so and yeah that we're
trying to go over the weekend for the
comics i mean it's it's one of the great
it's staples
wendy who runs it they run tight
shipments there's one heckler in the
front not during my set but during the
suns
yeah thursday night early show the other
early show
so some heck like you know kind of
heckling us on and i walk out and
they're gone like what the [ __ ] and
it sounds like dude i didn't have to
roast them literally they kept talking
security kicked i'm like whoa see that
that was a lot of security
at these especially at improvs and the
helium stuff it's just not relaxed
a little loosey-goosey like shoot me
probably could yeah
it's like very tampa's little yeah
there's a couple of strong trunky drunks
denver is not they're on a tight
tight ship when you put your cell phone
in a pouch oh yeah
they take all your cell phones at the
front it's pretty great it's one of the
best clubs of all time beautiful but uh
i was it's funny because i was doing uh
prep i still had like a little anxiety
about going back to denver
yeah and i was doing press on up friday
morning with willie b
uh lewis and uh i love lewis he loves
you man yeah they're great that that
whole group is the whole group
with uh david he's a captain kathy yeah
i went to school with her
brother jonathan but then and also he
does it with that giant football player
that's uh no uh uh scott hastings
yeah there's scott hastings who i love
he does it with a football player
but uh who there's a giant guy who you
played with in colorado
matt mcchesney yes yes he didn't do it
with matt was in lineman
matt was a alignment yeah defensive matt
sat me down and i said
explain to me just show me how
complicated one play is
and he has a lineman oh my god he broke
he broke it down
and i was like this is people have no
idea how complicated someone is yeah but
what
uh what was cool too being back home is
dude so they all of them were talking
about you
they love you back there man really yeah
they love you yeah they're great it was
so cool to see them made me feel so good
yeah yeah being back home made me feel
so good yeah i don't know why i had
anxiety over it you should never saw
everybody
sold out came up there and did all that
did it did the damn thing
were there as a fighter and now you're
there as a comic it's a big deal
yeah it's a big deal man you're doing
all the that's what they said you don't
remember like last time when we were
there
it was you me nate marquart cowboy
cerrone this is way back in the day when
you guys were all fighting yeah i know
and and i was the comic and you guys
were coming to my show right
yeah and i was doing old [ __ ] man oh
this is a long time ago and now you're
you're there doing your own thing
and they all came out willie b came
lewis catholic they're just good people
you remember i've noticed people for
since you were 18 15 years
at least wow since you know it was like
yeah willie b's been doing uh radio he's
been the number one
jockey out there since 92. god dang
i love danny it was so crazy to see them
in yeah it was
it was right it's just so was it it was
surreal man yeah because you didn't have
to do press
you were you were sold out but you just
went there and and those were my friends
yeah like those are like legit friends i
was excited to do it
i was so excited to do it man it was
just cool to see them nostalgia
yeah and then dave you know dave logan
he's a play-by-play for the broncos and
he's like
he he was a all-american at cu played 10
years
like he's mister mr colorado it was cool
sitting down
shooting the [ __ ] with him and him being
like you know how crazy it is you do set
up
comedy and you sell out shows and like
travel like you know
nuts that is yeah i was like you know
how nuts is what you do
and we're just going back and forth i
have so much respect for him man you
guys kissed
oh no we [ __ ] what just kidding dave's
right
just kidding speaking of he's the top
high school coach there you know who
else came
out and a lot of people i posted a
picture of my aunt nubby and my mom
yeah i said is is brian going to stack
them which i don't appreciate who said
that
everybody god damn it you guys how dare
you that's private she said you're going
to stack them up and redempt all i said
i said how did i said i'm not going to
but there they are there's mom look at
mom giving the old
she's she's just kind of getting those
lips on her on her son there look at
that
look at that comic look at the comment
brian going to stack your mom and aunt
nubby
right off the top oh my god and it has
171
composure how ridiculous oh there's a
million of those oh that's outrageous
i thought it was funny though i love her
i would never or would i mom had a few
drinks started yelling
hate calling your boy is that right in
her place a little bit that'll put in
her place
listen you can go kiss klopp and kiss
him on the neck whatever you miss
is that right sometimes you miss oh i
like that i love seeing her though
my mama nubby my back clop club is the
kind of guy that when
when ladies when ladies not necessarily
girls but when the ladies
of you know 35 plus years old when they
start drinking
they start hanging on the big man he's
only 240 right now he's cotton
weight he's got a lot more shred city
though really he's doing great went over
and saw his kids on sunday morning he's
a
four-year-old and like his children a
one-year-old his children giants
his uh his oldest daughter has his exact
same build
not athletic though what it's
heartbreaking for him
how old is she she's four we don't know
you oh no you know
oh no you know look at me you know you
don't know
trust me you know you know come on you
guys like me and clap
we know at four my dad was like yeah
toss a football now watch this
yeah if that three when the kids are
playing i can toss the ball i'm like oh
watch this
oh you know your kids aren't that
like your son's not athletic so maybe
like oh hopefully
no trust me when you when tiger gets
around other kids well i see with tiger
because when he runs
there's no moving parts like it's all
one he's got traps already let's be
honest you know
push-ups he's jacked he's got traps i
mean when he runs
he runs as a unit so when my kids run
they run
i told you when they play tag my kids
play tag with uh with
their parents are both olympic gold
medalists one downhill skier
the other swimmer sprinter those kids
they were they were
dude my kids were playing tag with them
i i i was the i was it
these kids were i think at the time
what's crazy me is i mean i mean i knew
club wasn't a good dad but he's like
mr dad yeah but if tom brady was a kid
you'd see him run you'd be like that
kid's all loosey-goosey and lanky
no let's see he's not throwing a
football like oh i could there's
something there
something you can tell i'm not saying
you can tell if he's gonna be an nfl
player yeah we can tell
sports might be in his future like with
cops daughter he's even collapsed like
she's not
she's not there it's not for but she has
the exact build as her dad
big strong girl like long she's tall for
four
yeah just like just just there yeah but
cloud hung out with us a ton like we
went to dinner on thursday night
and then we came to the show backstage
and i saw him
uh it was phil heath nope didn't see
phil
willie b came uh salt had uh dinner with
lauren
you know the head strength coach of the
broncos yep looked a little stressed out
right they're
owned four now oh they're on four um
man oh man yes all my friends jeff
suskin
[Music]
it was cool man my dad came i saw him
chin how it was weird because you know
uh my opener derek
is black and we're in the back room and
my dad's back there it's always weird
that family in the green room
and you know derek's memphis black you
know black and my dad just saw someone's
like
damn you like that fried chicken like i
was like
huh it was like a screeching halt i was
like what
what did he just say oh no but they were
talking about food oh my
god my dad grew up like my dad started
speaking about his best friends
well like all grown up we're black guys
i've never seen this side so he goes
into
oh oh you like some collard greens i was
like oh
borderline racist i feel like i better
yeah
yeah kind of like you do when you see a
black day brian does the same
old guys do this runner yeah
goes and you know brian's always like
joking around one bite is damn what's up
doug
yeah i go my man yeah so you always say
oh my man up in this [ __ ] he always
does it
i would never do that yeah you do every
time no
dog i'm like why are you saying what's
up what's up
easy negro well we have to edit that
aren't we
negro my negro you think we're good
that's fine why
that why why is that yeah i hear that on
tv yeah
my openers this weekend were both
african-american
that i brought with me you brought two
or just one i brought
derek my buddy herman uh reese
and uh and malik basil mount molech b
who's the boxer and they were both they
they both have been doing set of two
years they they did a great job they did
a [ __ ] good because you're always
nervous you know i don't know
they did a great job great job it was so
fun i don't know
i don't know yeah you'll see him
um yeah it's very strange my dad did
that it was hilarious
and then i went on stage and roasted him
in front of everybody
which he had fun with with it yeah yeah
never seen my guy my dad around a black
guy like that
that's hilarious it was fantastic
because i
i was doing something with um nick young
from uh swaggy p yes swaggy p and he had
his friend there they were both
large very athletic african-american
gentlemen okay
and nick's a great guy just a great guy
who loves fashion yeah kind of an
artistic side to him
and uh shy quiet and uh
i'm in there and i meet him we're going
to do a thing together we're doing this
and one of the producers comes in i've
never seen like he's
a regular white fella and he comes in
and he's like put a little flavor what's
that man you guys good you good i swear
to god he's going
you good okay okay and i'm like dude you
got to be kidding me right now
and when he left i said to them i go hey
i just want you guys to know he doesn't
talk that way
that's you've you've dealt with him
before he he's as white as i am
and maybe they panic i don't it's very
no you want everybody wants to be liked
and everybody wants everything yeah but
when you
want to be like don't talk like he just
wanted them to know
that he's there's this feeling where
you're what you
i'm white but i get it and i'm not i'm
white but i also like
black culture right which is so strange
that you see this all the time
that's why bill burr is such a gangster
would you know that his wife is black
no bill burx so what yeah he's never
changed
but a lot of times when you see a white
dude with a black girl yeah there's a
little bit of
no not ethnic in his tank we're like all
right dude you don't have to act like
that
just be cool i find that it is
everything get embarrassing a white guy
acting black i need to name something
worse i get embarrassed
maybe when asian people drop the n-bomb
or mexicans i'm like
well why are you doing that asians who
act black
that's a thing now no i know i'm very
aware of it
i feel like that i i'll take that almost
more than a white guy acting black
really i feel weird when i see like a
5-2 little asian girl
all of a sudden speaking like she's like
some black girl from north carolina i
find it hilarious but if you if you look
at me so uncomfortably
i celebrate it if you look at the 60s so
so when when the rock and roll
sort of revolution came along even
zeppelin the who all those british bands
what they were doing if you that's why
when they may have been british but the
blues they're they're they were what
they they were copying yeah the blue to
the point where they were copying not
only abused musicians blues musicians
to the point though where stanley crouch
talks about this who's a black scholar
he said
if you look at how jim morris and janice
joplin they all they all had heroin
problems they got into heroin sure he
said these were middle-class white kids
that were charlie parker and all the
people that they used to watch
they all had like billie holiday they
all had heroin problems
and he said here's the difference all of
them and he said here's the difference
though
when you got someone like billie holiday
when you got the they were
they were coming up in a segregated
country where they had to come in
through the back
door they they basically you know and
they had
there's all kinds of baggage that comes
with that survivor guilt all kinds of
[ __ ] like why am i lucky and everything
else
they were trying to overcome the pain of
their
shitty existence these games holiday all
these
yeah yeah billy holliday grew up in
harlem she started i'll tell you a story
about her in a second but
but she they had it hard
but and they're saying and and and
stanley crowd said now you had
guys like jim morrison jennifer zaplin
who their heroes were black
a lot of them had drug problems but they
were subscribing
to that lifestyle 100
there something like like but like billy
billy
i'm just saying but like uh it's all
like uh
um the drug culture that so when but
like but like with nirvana right with
him
like he had an addiction that's more
removed that's a little bit more removed
because he had a stomach issue
what i'm saying is that if you look at
jim morgan right the advent of heroin
that came in it was weed and
psychedelics that was a different thing
psychedelic when
heroin came in this was white kids
seeing there's a long legacy and a long
history of a lot of the black
jazz and blues musicians who had heroin
problems
and so there was this this thing where
it became kind of cool
to nod off it was cool yeah and if you
look at like
even mick jagger they they all went
through this period of drug
drug sort of addiction and and territory
though yeah
but but but crouch said look it's one
thing to be in a shitty place
like billie holiday learned she could
sing because she used to clean houses
with her mother
and she would sing the old blues songs
to keep herself company
and one day her mother was it was harlem
is the middle of the winter
her mother was going to get thrown out
they just they shouldn't get evicted
back then there was no
we're just getting see you later in the
middle of winter in new york
contract when it's [ __ ] 15 below yeah
i think it was our mother or grandmother
it was
it was really serious i mean they were
gonna freeze i mean it was gonna be a
real problem
and she went to every speakeasy as a
young girl and sang
and picked up 13 [ __ ] dollars off
which back then was everything
these guys were crying on their beer
because they couldn't believe it and
that's how she paid the rent that's how
she became a singer
and they asked to ask billy how they go
what what drives you and she said hunger
and they said
what do you mean hunger and she said no
hunger i was hungry for real legit
hungry that was a legit house
bob marley said the same thing they were
talking about marmalade this banner said
we were hungry we were we were legit
hungry yeah you know we were that poor
and you you know so singing was the way
to get the [ __ ] out of there you're
crazy if these shoes aren't influenced
by the black culture dude
i was going to say those are some flashy
easy those are some flashy shoes crazy
i got to my house after my tampa i got
to my house
my boy stevie stevie blue eyes staying
with me
love them well we were the best one of
our best friends now
and i i walk in and who's sitting in my
at my kitchen counter a young female
yeah a young lady named nicole aniston
i'm a fan of her work
you know nicole i've watched i've
studied film on her
like she's beckham jr yes okay so you
know nicole anna oh yeah
well there she is she's a 10.
is it fair to say she might be at a
hardcore 10
yeah now the 10 of 10. she's the 10 of
tens
and that's that's his girl that's his
girl
and so she's there and i'm like i don't
know i didn't i don't
know but i know i'm not familiar with
the work but i'm gonna get familiar now
did you do some homework i'm going to i
haven't done it yet
gonna i'm gonna didn't have time gonna
get it gutter though
so i uh i see this and
uh i look in my fridge and my fridge is
well all my eggs and everything's thrown
away
where's the he made all of them no it's
all
like vegetable and weird vegan [ __ ] oh
she's vegan
yeah but he he's vegan he's been
pretending to be a vegan
stevie because stevie's sliding her dm
since i'm a vegan he goes
me too so he's been lying to her
for [ __ ] two years she's gonna hear
this oh yeah
yeah that's how you're outing your
friend i'm out of here my friend because
hey nicole
she knows hold on she needs to know i'm
vegan hey you're not a [ __ ] me nicole
it's crazy stevie's lying i'm actually
strict vegan
right i believe in all have you had that
whopper burgers
that's his burger let's try it brandon
that's his girl
so i'm like stevie and he goes i know i
haven't told her we go to dinner that
night
he goes he goes i want a steak and let's
get the fish too
i know with without her i go what the
[ __ ] is dude i haven't eaten meat all
weekend i can't see that well for real
my sight and i'm i'm and i'm and i have
no energy
that's hilarious i was laughing so hard
i go i'm talking about this one you
create a bit about that i told him i was
going to talk about him he needs to
create a bit about him going vegan for
that's how hot she is
that he needs to create a bit about that
i would eat just sausage
he threw away my [ __ ] he threw it
away from my fridge
dude yeah take one for the team bro i
guess i had to
and i was i was like she's got her eyes
you get lost in her eyes oh dude
stevie's got some blue eyes
[ __ ] his eyes they look like little poo
they look like pieces of
[ __ ] they look like poo slits yeah i got
lost in her eyes
you're talking about a stone cold tanner
she's a stone cold fox as i said i've
lost
a lot of nuts to her you know this
stevie let's be cool man
really yeah she's a hall of famer dude
something else
just in a t-shirt sweats couldn't be
more normal
couldn't be you would normally well
would you expect what do you mean no
more no
would you expect that expected to crawl
across the floor and be like you're so
hot
no she wasn't very normal nice girl nice
cal
yeah so there you go well done well done
steve you outed
he needs to be added i did it and nicole
stevie is not a vegan but your boy is
here
no i haven't had me in a long time
my mama's one of the members of pete
that's true
and uh there's nothing on my body made
of animals god damn it
you got leather shoes bro hey that's a
snake print but it was a mean snake
that was a snake you're wearing a snake
and a leopard and that that's crocodile
listen there was goddamn there was a
snake and he ate a ton of rabbits and i
didn't like it
and that's why i'm wearing these shoes i
want to document it you'll go you'll
change your diet that's when you know
you like a girl when you'll
change your diet the whole weekend poor
and the lie and keep a lie going for two
years
stevie kept the line going for two years
for two years i hope she hears this
um yeah i don't know what i'd be willing
to do
what would you be willing to do for a
girl that that strength uh
that's whatever but i'm saying what if
she was like hey you gotta you gotta
not what do you love like not drink wine
or now i'm too old i don't give a [ __ ]
what if she said
what if she was an alcoholic what if it
was j lo and she was like hey you can't
have
any wine i'd be like i'd like see one
see i'd be like
see you jayla shut the [ __ ] up i just
went with that ass
i wouldn't drink in front of her no i
become an uh alcoholic here
yeah i drink you know i don't drink at
home because i feel like people judge me
i don't drink in la when i'm on the road
though
[ __ ] it you're you're mr you're you're
mr whiskey
mr whis you're not wine guy you're
you're mr whiskey get your wine out of
my [ __ ]
really wine all day now how about j shop
threw up drinking uh whiskey
what he just he had one shot of the
strand of hands denver whiskey
and when this you know how small the
green room is and tommy works yeah we're
all gather around he's going
what he's trying to hold it in that's
the best price you want
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
i see him go
and i'm like oh [ __ ] and he grabs the
trash bag and goes
why the whiskey got [ __ ] with the the
shot just
the shot was nasty oh man it's it's not
a thing you shoot you should be sipping
still he's [ __ ] it was yeah it's like
don't you get really mad
people buy me tequila shots i'm like i'm
like no that's okay thanks so much
let it touch my lips oh you're a [ __ ] i
uh i drink a double jack on the rocks
before every show double check double
jack
makes it fun man and then you do another
double jack uh yeah
you don't do glasses full of whiskey
it's not you can handle it you're big
do you get drunk at all do you feel
buzzed a little bit a little buzz i love
it
yeah i love it on the buzz on stage yeah
oh someone gave me a nicotine gum
nicorette you're not talking about uh
nicotine
man i'm still not used to i tried it i
get a little dizzy i get a little
nauseous on it strong
i want strong jobs so i know so i did a
half of a a piece of the gum
i still didn't feel great strong i don't
know if my body [ __ ] with nicotine i
wanted to
you're pretty you're pretty healthy and
clean so i feel like
i don't know why you're doing it right
for your brain
and if it gives you a little brush i
don't see any ctes from you buddy
but not yet dude i mean you might be a
little impulsive
ferrari but you know what i mean i make
tons of money uh what are you saying
hey man sorry dude yeah
what's up bro nothing why are you
looking at me like that
i don't know vegan i'll be vegan
what would you be willing to do chin for
like say your dream girl true love
true love hey true love hate true love
guy or girl
don't care no judgment you met him or
her probably him
if you what would you be willing to give
up what if he said no more playing the
guitar
of course not there's no way no way
really
i would take your card she was hot
enough
yeah nope i'd keep my ferrari for some
some hot girl
she was like i hate that car that
represents horses
and i love horse like suck it
really suck you wouldn't
i don't know what i would what would i
what would you be able to give up chin
what if she said no more eating uh
korean barbecue
come on she's my favorite dude i'm
talking a girl who's a
[ __ ] child i don't checks off every
box
that you guys are soul mates why
wouldn't you stop drinking korean
barbecue
no hell no that's my love what if it's
your dream man
and that doesn't change anything in that
case nothing i mean
no nothing no i would be more picky
about stuff
about her i'm giving him nothing zero
i'm not giving her anything i won't grow
my hair for her either i like marriage
i like it i like it i like jesus christ
you still you stay single
appreciate it see how that goes i will
hear me hot single dude
for a while i don't care you don't care
yeah you like he's got his music
yeah man like music has music and korean
barbecue
yeah cat did you have to give anything
up with your man uh with my man no but
i've had this conversation
with some of my girlfriends before oh
yeah and it's the term we use is
life ruining good dick so there are
and i think it's with the reverse too
where it's like life ruining good [ __ ]
like what would you do for some really
good dick
for sure i think if it was like michael
b
jordan like i love that man he's a
beautiful man
a gay man because and he's gay you said
that
hey even if he is he don't really care
no i don't care you have gossip no i
don't care
i let him ruin my credit score oh i'd do
that
damn for some life-ruining good dick you
like black guys you like your sister
oh yeah i don't discriminate against me
neither i like all colors
if you're fine you're fine that's it
well so michael b jordan who else
um you know the b stands for basketball
chris christilia joked
uh somebody older idris elba [ __ ]
fine
another black guy uh keep going i like
it um i do too he's like i like these
older too i like that you like the older
man
oh there's a couple dancers there's one
dancer who's a girl
i would let her ruin my dancer a dancer
dancer for what she's a hip-hop dancer
about the twerk king no like an actual
dancer she can twerk so you you you're
attracted to women
yes what's your name i don't know how to
spell her last name is that lesbian
voice yeah
it's a good thing i like your
i'm very physically attracted to i don't
think i ever get too kidding where i'm
sexually attracted to women but looking
yeah oh i love her
i know who she is amazing i swear to god
i did because i think she's such an
amazing dancer but she's
so good-looking beautiful oh dude you
got to see her dance
she dances with halsey dude you got to
see the way she dances 2.4 she was just
in the fenty um fashion show she's so
happy
she's so you got to see her dancing
there's going to be music and stuff
though
which all right let's just play first
and then just turn it down she's so
hot this one right here any of them
she's the one that's a good dancer i
can't believe it
for her yes i would let her ruin my life
i followed her and then i felt creepy so
i stopped following her because i'm
well everything you do is creepy oh my
god so good that's
nothing what's her deal she's perfect
just a beautiful girl
can dance her ass off she's as good as
it gets who is this hip-hop
angel scroll down go go scroll down some
more home you got to see more you got to
see more dancing look at the muscles
i'm not too into the muscles you know uh
keep going
bro sim what is her little deal
she's short huh she's about five six she
looks like she's short
five five maybe i can't call anyone
short i'm the show how tall are you cat
like five two i would say she's around
your height maybe either way i'd let her
ruin my life
oh me me too so would i there's just
certain people i would
allow she's top of the list she's a girl
yeah perfectly fine dang
she's gorgeous oh yeah jade bug
98. she born 98 look at her
she is younger she's younger than me
dude oh my she's super young
jade bug 98. she's like 21-22
why is she so famous though because
she's not she's an amazing dancer
i can't believe this because i found her
on instagram
i went down the route you didn't find
her i swear i did
and i followed her i was following you
because i'm an old man
and i felt creepy but i i now that i've
rediscovered her i just like watching
her dance
she's so good-looking oh my god she's so
good
yeah i mean she's impossible it's cool
to get introduced to
oh they're smacking each other that's
that's oh my
word
ooh they're serious though sometimes it
makes feel awkward when they're so
serious dancing
when they're all something else
i'm just like you know what let's take
it down a half a notch
jesus christ you're not right she's vast
paul's you cat
she's shorty why do you say that you can
just tell yeah i can tell
you can tell god damn she
is delicious yes sir it's jade bug
shout out to jade bug there you go go
ahead
all right watch this
turn this up a little bit or you can
who's the ugly that's a tough part
just kidding no the one on the left is
amazing too
you don't like her what compared to the
bug
the buggy guy pretty funny the buggy
makes everybody look like [ __ ] though
i don't know i like damn high heels and
the one on the left is hot buggy okay
buggy don't talk to me about her dude i
found her first
didn't find [ __ ] shut up oh my god
look at that shin you wouldn't quit
korean bbq for that
honestly she's not my type i might watch
everybody in this room all right i think
she's talented as hell dancing not your
type she's not my type though
i don't know like really not my type
which i could tell i can see the beauty
in here i can see the beauty in here
why don't you go to that middle one for
me why why do you not into muscular
athletic beautiful girls
she's 10.
you are um into guys i don't care hey if
there's a girl
that's more like look at her yeah look
at her friend yeah look at her friend on
the left
we got to start dancing bro dude i want
to get into dance and i'm not kidding
she's in l.a we can go take a dance
class from her okay
it'd be creepy though you know of course
her friend is delicious
yeah dancers are the best there's
dancers and everybody else brandon
there's [ __ ] dancers and everybody
else i've been saying this from day one
i'm god you know what i'm not doing the
podcast anymore go dance dude
all i want to do is dance all i want to
[ __ ] do is dance maybe i should
create a podcast dance is spider-man in
the bug
oh dance is in me it's
i want to be in dance
yeah you feel i feel you look at her
there
yeah let's move on dude sometimes people
are so
hot it's painful you know it makes me
mad yeah me too it makes you aggressive
like why didn't we meet you know oh one
white guy that i think
was attractive thanks cat you thought 30
minutes
he's dead yeah the one white guy's dead
huh
he's also weird because he dated a 16
year old
do you remember that i don't yeah though
he was like
in his legal though is it it
it was it's not and i don't know what
happened
he met her on vacation when she was 16
with her parents in hawaii
that's not aggressive yeah that's
aggressive interesting he was already
like
a star in fast and furious
oh wow man she's not even hot either
tarik was good friends with him and said
he's just such a great guy
wow that's so weird did you date that 16
year old
that's a very young girl
i guess when they met was handsome yeah
he wasn't he was super handsome
the prettiest white boy in my opinion
um yeah he's up there he's good
more more so than like thor um he's like
i don't think he's pretty i think he's
rugged
rugged hot yeah he's hot i think he is
pretty
yeah that's fair it was cars too man
yeah he was an attractive dude try the
other white
well ashton kutcher no hot white dudes
it's hard out here for a hot white guy
huh brian
uh no you're here what
what well maybe a little bit
i'm cute you are a little cutie
you are a cutie
yeah i can't think of uh yeah that's
interesting what'd you guys do this
weekend
what'd you do kat um i went to go to the
el capitan
theater on thursday and i watched hocus
pocus it was
cool cause a classic halloween movie but
there were people in there who were a
little
too excited about a movie that came out
in the late 90s
were they older women yeah they were
older women who were
gasping and reciting the lines and
acting as if this was the first time
that they saw it
singing along it was too much it's a
good movie though did you dress up
no i just went to go watch it a lot of
people dressed up it's
still not close enough to halloween for
me yet to dress up yeah but
people are hype about halloween oh yeah
i don't give a [ __ ]
oh my favorite yeah my favorite holiday
my family's too yeah my son
asked me since last month every night
before we go to bed at halloween
does he know what he wants to be yep i'm
the boogeyman from nightmare before
christmas i have the whole outfit
he's jack we have the whole outfit for
him we got like six months ago
and then my girls uh the sally oh that's
dope
you'll be nightmare before christmas
that's cute he's me cute as [ __ ]
uh yeah halloween's dope man uh we
always go to nightmare before christmas
so that's gonna be me
back there looking like a jackass baby
but i want to because we're going to the
disneyland uh
halloween nights which is so dope it's
all haunted
uh nightmare before christmas theme all
of disneyland they shut it down the kids
can trick or
and uh isn't that a doll scene no
because they limit tickets it's already
sold out so you have to buy like six
months in advance
but um parents can't wear costumes
only kids yeah they don't want creepy's
that's a bummer yeah looking forward to
it though
you were saying uh shout out to
halloween you were saying you were
watching hard knocks kevin
yeah man hold on yeah yeah it's week
it's
week four the nfl season i know
and you just watch i just can't believe
i'm a latecomer to it because it's
right up my alley and i didn't realize
that this has been a bad
that was a bad one like this was weak
last year's the browns was so much
better
really for that i think it was baltimore
i forget but they've been way better
when when
john gruden opens up and goes you guys
you know i hear a lot about dreams it's
my dream to play in the nfl i have a
dream to play anyhow
i don't like dreams i like [ __ ]
nightmares and i want you to turn
somebody's dream into a [ __ ]
nightmare
like it's just like this is the pros
business it's military it's like
well that's no that's professional
sports yeah it's and that's and that's
watered down
watered down yeah that's like you
seemingly i don't like that one guy
who's missing
way worse that guy who missed practice
you know or he just wasn't going no
that guy's not he was he was from um
last chance you and he was a baller on
that juco team i forget where he went on
after that
and then i was surprised to see him on
hard knocks like damn he made he was a d
tackle but he was
lazy on last chance you but in the nfl
like
it just easy what are you talking about
so yeah so he did one drill and he's got
my foot's bothering me
and then john green's like oh you're not
practicing he's not practicing
let's cut the [ __ ] dead weight and
then he he was there for like two days
and got cut
oh he won't get picked up they told him
to go train every day to the trainer go
work out every day at the trainers
and so he got injured and you have to
see the trainer every day and do rehab
at like six in the morning it's a beast
but that's the way you get healthy so
you can be on the field
so if you miss that that goes down to
the coaches because they
every morning they go right who miss uh
training who is training they tell
him the coach goes oh he doesn't want to
be here go grooty said
gruden goes let's get some of these guys
let's get these guys who don't want to
practice let's get them the [ __ ] out of
here
that's life everybody should watch that
over and over again
to me when you see young people nobody
gives a [ __ ]
i i'm sorry your friends can't help you
your family actually can't help you at
the end of the day
like if you want to make something of
your life you that's
that is watch that because the world
goes like this i i know all your excuses
and some people have really good ones
it still doesn't matter they go get them
the [ __ ] out of here there's just too
many people there's only so much room at
the front of the plane
there's only so much room on the coast
there's only so much room that you know
there's only so many good views and you
got to compete for it otherwise
what do you want to do what do you want
what do you want to do nobody owes you
well nobody owes you anything yeah no
that kid just didn't want it bad enough
you just wanted excuses that's fine but
guess what the guy who really wants it
badly he gets that slot
no he's on the team yeah and he's on the
team this year and you know what that is
i call that fair
i call it force well that's the nfl's
only fit my dad said that
one time i said that to my dad that's
what's great about sports yeah you know
what my dad said
one time uh he said i was business i
don't know how you do it and i go it's
fair what business
show business yeah because i i wasn't
getting jobs you know yeah
and i was going through i was getting a
lot of rejections and uh and he said uh
i don't know how you do it man i don't
know how you do it i think it's just a
[ __ ] my mother's like it's a crazy
business it makes no sense i go it makes
a lot of sense it's actually very fair
whatever you want to say sometimes well
whatever you want to say
the people that i know that that become
huge like
like you know rather they're so they're
so disciplined
and they leave nothing to chance and
they're detail-oriented
when i look back at all myself look i'm
talented i've done well
but i there are a lot of opportunities
that for whatever reason and as i look
at it back it was because i didn't like
acting as much
but you know you you make whatever you
want happen
i know that sometimes things aren't fair
i know that i'm not saying that the
world does
but it i don't care nobody care doesn't
matter it doesn't matter no
it just doesn't what are your excuses
tell me i'll i'll give you
you know okay that's crazy that first
thought you realized that the first time
watching hard knocks though
is way worse i love it it's been way
worse where guys who
in this this season they and maybe it
was just the the the oakland raiders but
usually they'll show you like a young
guy who's like he's on the cusp of
making it and they show his family you
get so invested
in this free agent like god i hope he
makes it they find out
i get oh you get so invested in guys
yeah and then he gets [ __ ]
cut and like what the [ __ ] yeah and but
then it use it didn't show it this
season but they used to show him cutting
it
you just show the coach said you've seen
that the
camera's there and he's like it's just
not gonna work man we go through the
numbers and
you didn't make like that's as real as
it gets man i've seen that
oh and you know too it's the worst and
the the head coach
so i head coach the one who does it
right uh depends who you are
it depends though yeah it depends they
just
told me that like you just know and they
go they're not going to like get your
playbook
well that's that they're they're
that's what i leave that's what that
happened to you yeah get your playbook
but you know and
it's there's a weird sense of relief too
because you know i don't know it's weird
yeah it's sense relief but it's also
like ah [ __ ] that's a terrible that
devastating thing though
to not make it black and white though
you know brenda and i were talking
a long time ago if anybody's interested
in being successful and stuff
no but i mean you and i were talking
about no but we were talking about how
um
like we both for a long time just missed
in a lot of our life
and just keep changing your approach and
keep going and the one thing that we
always talk about is
like what's what's going on what
negative stuff is happening
what what's what what people are saying
what cool i'll just keep going
you just keep going it doesn't matter
you just keep going
you know just keep getting better that's
what's great about sports pretty black
that's what i love about stand up too
though in a way
it's pretty black and white you're
rather funny yeah either they're
laughing they're not and it's
very black and white and it and
especially comedy works you know comedy
works
that's why one reason i love comedy
works you know common works won't let
certain acts come there if they're not
legit comedians i know they
the the first year i was headlined they
wouldn't let me come in you know that
yeah i had to
have to go in on i think it was a
wednesday night and they were right
they were 100 yeah i had to come in on a
wednesday night do it one show
and then they went we'll see where
you're at and then we'll see if we'll
let you in next year and the year after
that yeah so i did that one night
just flew in for that remember just in
time so you know your hometown club
doesn't work that way
they need to see you in person to do one
night and that's
to see if you can headline the following
years so i did that
then went on some other city but i did
that got passed
and then that's how i got it that's what
i say to the weekend that's what i said
a lot of young comics who want to open
like feature and
i know certain people who are friends
and i and i go you you
i don't want to showcase you yet because
you're actually not ready to feature
right now
because what will happen is the clubs
are watching this oh oh man if you come
in and you're not ready you're watching
itching but you're not ready and it's
going to set you so far back sold out
crowd on saturday night bring the money
you can't have silence
oh man you can't be working they should
not play those those major clubs they do
not play
cobs uh i mean go through the whole list
there's certain areas where
if it's not going well man they're gonna
they're gonna change your approach
correct
not in a good way not in a good way not
in a good way
you either have the goods you know it's
okay it's what it is
but you know yeah the crowd's gonna let
you know it's not really up for debate
yep like oh man i thought i did good you
know man
there's no way they were talking there's
that there was some debate among the
seal teams from what i heard where
the training is i have to get your
trident is crazy because you go through
buzz but then you're invited
into a commando unit i get they call you
an fng a [ __ ] new guy
and then you kind of have to prove
yourself over the year you know it's a
long long process
but they were saying that you know a lot
of guys just get they can't deal with
the cold
in the water and they've been but most
of our wars are fought in deserts now
they're not fought you know
but you know the guys were like also but
but that's also part of mental toughness
and for whatever reason your body can't
handle it you know
it's not for you it's just not for you
no because there's a guy who can yeah
my neck is too long i would i would go
get
donuts and coffee the first day i can't
handle the cold it's not for you but
otherwise i can handle everything else
yeah
yeah you'd make it if it weren't for the
cold oh yeah yeah the seals yeah
you know because i can really dig deep
seals although you should know something
[ __ ]
what i did 50 push-ups
without stopping in the sand on my
knuckles
up and down yesterday two days ago
50 bro like 52. [ __ ] you did my age man
[ __ ] i wish i had somebody to high
five but i don't feel like high-fiving
anybody in this [ __ ] room
yeah yeah that's right and i got a
challenge to a little competition and i
was like
what friends do you hang out with [ __ ]
can't do 50 push-ups in the sand
all right excuse me okay dude don't
challenge me how many can you do
as whatever you can do way more
please don't do this you just say way
more yeah i'm not doing it now
please don't do this i'm not doing it
now but don't say way more because hey
what friends do you have though
why is everyone 18. it was me i bet you
can't chug this bear like me it was not
too old dude it was me molly and herman
and we were just [ __ ] around who
ma malek my buddy malik b who opened for
me oh okay
and he's great but he's 27 and you know
herman's [ __ ] 30.
and uh malik malek just he's a [ __ ]
complete goofball hilarious
hilarious yeah and just impressed the
[ __ ] out of me with his comedy this
weekend
and he uh he just goes uh he's got a
shirt off he just started lifting
because he just boxes
he's all skinny he started lifting but
he puts on muscle super fast
and he's like look at my back man it
looks like authority my back looks like
authority
i'm like laughing and then you guys are
on the beach we're about to go to the
meeting he goes i'm gonna do some
push-ups
he just starts doing push-ups because
these girls over there just being a
silly goose
and uh as he's gonna put you he's
looking at me he's looking at me because
i'm going you're not going all the way
down
he does 50 and 52 or 53 and so i had to
i had to get on there and [ __ ] do it
myself bro
you're welcome you had some cur i gotta
pee
hard before you decrement look man when
it comes to sleep
mattress is everything it's it's
everything dude and that's why
helix sleep it they make matches they
have a quiz it takes you just two
minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
oh wait so i'm not just sleeping on a
regular bed if you sleep on your side
you sleep some people sleep on the side
their back whatever it is
they they do if you're a hot sleeper if
you like a plush or firm bed
helix there's no more confusion no more
compromising on an average mattress
not all medics are made the same are
they they were they were rewarded best
overall mattress pick of 2019 by gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
fighter take their two-minute sleep quiz
the match you to customize mattress that
will give you the best
sleep ever cnn called it the most
comfortable mattress ever for couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle
providing individual support needs and
field preferences for each side
10-year warranty bro 10 years risk-free
trial as well for 100 nights
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for you sleep on it for a hundred nights
risk-free
that's crazy and helix is offering you
guys 120 125
off all mattresses uh for the t
fat k army all you got to go to is
com slash helixsleep.com that's helix
sleep um
h-e-l-i-x helix sleep
dot-com slash fighter for up to 125 off
your mattress order
get it oh you're a rider now this this
oh yeah you guys are talking to me i
know because brendan
brennan stays tight he's got some nice
legs got an apple box dude every morning
you look at my ig story it's been a long
time coming bro
peloton peloton yes i love the penthouse
it's the cause peloton bike the best
cardio machine on the planet brendan's
been a pro athlete
most of his life he's on that palette
i'm telling you man i do
hard work i've done hard workouts
whether it's football with ufc
whatever it is that peloton in my garage
at 7 a.m
it's hard man you've been doing it i'm
such a fan of this i asked to work with
them
um i love it man i freaking love it
you get a subscription all you need is
one subscription all you need you get
unlimited access so if you have a family
let's say all of us we could share one
bike
we all have four different accounts you
have all access all you need is one
subscription
that's all you need no commute no
reservations they have live classes on
demand classes and you have a screen
right with a lot you have a giant screen
and there's a bunch of different
trainers i only use one trainer called
ali
she's my favorite i use her i use robin
but you have your favorites man
and some are good the one i like they
have one where you can do classes
whether it's biking and uh like arms
so you ride the bike then you break and
do arms it's pretty damn
they have hour classes they have hit
classes
they have freaking um whatever music you
like hip-hop they have live djs
and it's the best music you can get to
you can pick you if you want to do just
a kanye west class you can do that
they have certainly i gotta get on i'm
telling you it's dope it's the only way
my ass isn't
400 pounds by riding this thing because
i don't have time to go to the gym
peloton is the way to go it's fun 100
off accessories peloton is offering the
t5k listeners
100 off accessories when you purchase
the pelton bike
and get a great cardio workout for your
home
go to one peloton.com use promo code the
fighter to get started
that's one peloton.com promo code
the fighter p-l-o-t-o-n peloton
current events let's do current events
it's rock [ __ ]
monday it's actually [ __ ] [ __ ] rock yeah
it's [ __ ] rock
talk sometimes it's rock [ __ ] thursdays
so it's my it's rock [ __ ] thursdays but
it's [ __ ] rock mondays
and that's the most important thing
let's just keep rolling because i could
pull down the fort as i said my coffee
i'm drinking my coffee from funnel mill
um
where my my uh they're from taiwan
originally and they uh they calibrate
the water the water must be you gave me
last week it was delicious
yeah yeah it's the best coffee funnel
mill on broadway
santa monica shout out to funnel mill
yeah it's delicious dude if you want if
you get coffee that's where you should
go
it's just strong enough too i know yeah
that's good did i give you the iced
american it was i don't know
it was iced i think i gave you the ice i
think i gave you the iced
mocha it's the ice mocha cobra it didn't
taste uh whatchamacallit it didn't taste
sweet it's the mocha truffle cold brew
oh okay our chocolate truffle it's a
chocolate chocolate cold brew
ice and the ice cubes are made from
coffee
oh yeah they don't [ __ ] they don't
they're not they
they they brew their own coffee and then
freeze that and that's their
ice cubes the water is calibrated what's
that mean
i have no idea it just means that the
water is the perfect ph they do it on a
computer
it's a ten thousand dollar machine don't
[ __ ] taste
clean yeah very clean yeah they're
they're freaks
he cooks his own ginger i mean it
they're they're they're nuts there
they're nuts
here it's like a laboratory it's a
laboratory you can get a hundred dollar
uh cup of coffee there a hundred that's
too much yeah you get a 38
cup of coffee they have the most
specialty coffees in the world and they
will not serve it with milk
you will not get you will not serve it
you will you will take their suggestion
and that's the way it is
yeah jt and teresa
nice real quick brian do you think you
could i'm just curious because you're
doing push-ups now and everything yeah
do you think you could beat me
anonymously i don't know
i'm not that good at it but i'm not that
great at it i'm just wondering probably
but i don't know you have a long arm
are you strong i'm definitely strong
yeah
but i wonder how i'm gonna arm wrestle
okay we'll do it eventually we're gonna
arm myself at that desk
or even there wherever chin does this
all the time he's always trying to
assert dominance over
i'm not trying to assert i'm just
letting people know chin's korean
friends are some of the toughest people
in the world they have han
koreans and vietnamese you guys are both
you both come from some of the toughest
people of all time
more korean fact
vietnamese guy gave you that scar on
your shirt korean
korean no the vietnamese have never been
conquered ever the only country i can
think of
that's never been colonized they they've
been fighting they were fighting the
chinese the americans the french
they're all england no the vietnamese of
course it's in england never been never
been never been
england's never been conquered though
they had they were colonized by the
french but
they they also kicked them out i mean
they're just no joke
england yeah england was a colonizer
yeah but they've never been
yeah yeah yeah england throwing around
those stupid facts bro
sorry man well you're holding that stare
on me
dude you're aggressive long arms
what do we got all right first one how's
your plantar fasciitis
oh i got i got custom uh as a battery
insoles
it's getting there it's gonna take a
little while it's getting there i
cut some insoles from road runners
i got a guy road rack i got a very
famous
uh physical therapist who can help you
re
really famous really really well known
careful famous works with all the best
athletes with plantar fasciitis and
stuff what do you say to do
you have to see i'll put you in touch
with them yeah i think i think but i
think these are helping
because i just put these insoles in all
my shoes yeah
okay seem to be helping it's pretty
amazing how you do it man because
i think it's called road runners bring
that up gender in santa monica you go in
you put you you just stand on this
little like squishy thing
scans your foot that you lift your foot
they put the
the sole like the insole in it and then
it molds to your foot
you walk out seven minutes later i'm
doing that
road runner sports that's it dude that's
where i did it
i'm going to do it now you're right in
santa monica right here
right off the third street there i'll be
doing it yeah it literally takes like
seven or eight minutes my feet are like
90 bucks there it is perfect foot
you know i just wish it was a little a
little cushier you know i wish there was
like a gel
thing a little crusher yeah but it helps
my foot because like you know it's good
these are flat shoes but with the
insoles everyone told me get custom
insoles man
you should do it just for the [ __ ] i'm
going to i'm old i need it yeah
go ahead and give me uh give me what we
got here curt events
actually also real quick i heard people
saying that since you guys do a lot of
shows
you cross your legs i do like if you
just put your feet down
when you're sitting down that like is
supposed to help cure it too really yeah
because all the shows you're always you
know crossing your legs yeah i do
because my back
and they said this helps yeah so just
putting your feet flat when you're
sitting down how long ago did you get
that information
probably two weeks ago come on bro i
figured you would see
crazy how many people suffer from
planters there's so many yeah
damn ed mccaffrey who was a famous
denver bronco forever suffered so bad
from planets one of the reasons he
retired
he opened a bunch of planners like foot
shops in denver
so he can go there and get custom
insoles because he had to retire because
wow
yeah all right what do you got jen
so the 72 year old man was recently
arrested
for murder um one night he woke up to
a loud bang outside of his home he
looked outside the window and noticed
that somebody was trying to break in
with a pickaxe
so he grabbed his gun went downstairs
and
he shouted at the burglar saying if you
come any closer i will
shoot you the burglar then proceeded to
run away
and the man shot what he claims to be
one
shot and he didn't hear a body drop he
thought that guy ran off
so he went back into his home and he
fell asleep the following morning when
he woke up he noticed that man's body
on his uh driveway where the guy was
trying to run off to so he shot him in
the back
so he called the police the police came
and they did an investigation
and his neighbors say that they heard
three gunshots
and cops only found one bullet uh shell
so they think that he hid the other two
so that's why he got arrested for murder
so is he going to prison for life now
for murder uh he hasn't been sentenced
he just got arrested well if you're if
they're escaping any gun
anybody any gun store will tell you if
you shoot somebody in the back
in your own home you are in big trouble
and if he's got stuff in his hands you
you're going to be at the very least
you'll you'll be poor because you're
going to get sued by the family
there's a thousand things you have to
deal with and you can be charged for
murder or manslaughter for sure
even you were not being threatened but
this guy um
man yeah i wonder how they're going to
do that well the guy was running the guy
was running he's
out of the way from his house yeah he
was trying to break into the house when
he
uh heard the old man come out and saw
the gun he started to try to run away
and he got shot in the back that's my
thing i don't condone this but my thing
is if
this guy who's dead now [ __ ] happens if
you're dumb enough to break into a
stranger's house with a pickaxe and you
get
shot there has to be some sort of
responsibility on his part they go
well no he's just he but he's getting
away
but then he can't shoot him if he shoots
them and injures them
no because he here's there has to be
some responsibility yes but but
property crime like if you're if you're
if somebody is taking your property
unless you feel like you are being
physically
like so this is a really hard case but
in a lot of states
even if a guy's clubbing your dog to
death in front of you
oh jesus that's your property you're not
allowed to shoot him
if it's in your house though if it's in
your house it's gonna be okay
because of course but but but but in
your house even the cops will tell you
shoot a gun shoot a bullet into the
ceiling
so you can say i warned him and then you
should whatever you do
you are going to have trouble whatever
you do you are going to keep
charging you're going to have to be okay
if you're in your house
and you shoot him in his face not if
he's yes correct
i've had main chemistry that's exactly
right am i girls but if you shoot him
yeah you shoot him in the back
they deal with this all right but if you
shoot him in the back you're gonna have
some trouble you're still gonna be okay
if it's in the house
it's gonna be an issue yeah but if you
can say oh he's threatening he's gonna
be always
doing this he wants to turn we want to
go upstairs you're gonna be all right oh
100
if he's walking upstairs and you've got
your kids up there also
if there's a robber in your house just
who gives a [ __ ] about lawyers
just shoot the [ __ ] guy yeah there's
that too yeah but there has to be
so stupid so listen i don't know this
guy i know the exact circumstances
but if a guy is trying to come in my
house with a [ __ ] pickaxe
and i go dude i'm gonna shoot and he
goes [ __ ] you and then
you know what i'm saying that's
different but if he if he drops the
pickaxe and starts running and you shoot
at him you're going to jail for murder
you're in deep trouble yeah i don't know
if that guy should because here's the
thing
that guy wouldn't commit murder unless
you didn't decide to break into his
house
so is that guy a murderer or is he
scared who's not you know
he doesn't do well in the stressful
situations but that murder wouldn't them
dna doesn't care i'm just saying that
that's whatever i'm saying
but that murder wouldn't have happened
if this robber decided to break into
this person's house i i think so the
to me the guy who's murdered has to take
some responsibility
because if he never broke in that house
or attempt to he would be alive yeah but
it's not a capital offense he doesn't
deserve to die
the problem is you're talking about
murder and the problem yeah but he's not
a sniper so let's say he was like
with the shoe you have to enforce this
law because what happens is if somebody
is actually running from your house
or even if they're walking away from
your house and you shoot them in the
back
you're opening up an entire pandora's
box i agree it's not your
property anymore even if it is your
front yard you're not a threat
and what if he says what what about this
let's say you just pick it right trying
to get in his house
he says hey dude what shouts hey if you
keep coming on the [ __ ] shoot you
the guy goes oh yeah that's cool i'll be
back man i'm gonna murder your wife and
kids next time you're out of town
doesn't matter that's a terrorist threat
but
you can't shoot him you can't shoot
somebody for what they say that's
interesting yeah you can't say you shoot
somebody for saying [ __ ] you you can't
shoot somebody for calling you
uh racial empathy you can't do anything
i agree but if he's trying to break in
your house there has to be some
consequences you let him break into the
house and then you shoot him if you want
yeah
you can't yeah you can't do it with
walking away yeah i'm just saying that
guy would still be alive if he didn't
decide to
break into this dude's house that's
right so there has to be some
responsibility there
there should be some leniency on the guy
shooting the guy
there'll be some you know like i'm sure
he's fine it's gonna be interesting to
follow this case
because i think he's gonna do real time
well here's
here's where he's [ __ ] if it's one
shot i think they're like all right he
didn't fight he's not [ __ ] shot a
warning shot
yeah like shot in the accident hit the
dude i'm old i don't sleep well
three yeah you're trying to [ __ ] [ __ ]
the dude up
but again the robber would still be
alive if you decide to break in this
random dude's house
so it has to be some responsibility
there yeah
this will make my day law right yeah but
make my day laws very specific this
doesn't cover you
you're in trouble no he's kind of [ __ ]
he's shot from
i'm saying homeboy'd still be alive if
he wasn't a crook we got to take that
into account here
don't break in people's house you won't
get shot in the back well that's true
there's that
there's that but that guy didn't doesn't
make a lot of good choices most people
don't like to break in the house with
pickaxes
it's loud it's a loud what happened to
your [ __ ]
bad you ever heard of picking locks you
suck at burglary
all right next one yeah so last week
brendan you talked about aaron carter
right
yeah i did i'm trying to keep calling
cool so
aaron carter recently got a
large face tattoo amid all of these
weird um like allegations with his
brother and his sister
oh where do you see him stable he also
posted something on instagram i saw a
couple days ago
claiming that his older brother nick
raped an older woman that his mother
used to take care of
and he added the fbi on instagram wow
what a terrible human being
there's something well he's uh wildly
wrong and he looks like he's going to
kill himself well didn't he yeah it's
just a matter of time is there a
countdown thing um just kidding
is he uh but he also came out about how
he's bisexual too right
yes doctor oz bisexual
he something it was something else do i
think he's sick with something
um not talent uh yeah when he was a kid
he was pretty talented
have you ever seen him when he's a
little kid no but pretty talented he's
just uh he's just not
uh him and his brother just hate each
other now
yeah they had one tragic family so they
got taken advantage of
a tattoo not a bad body
is that meth did you get you skinny like
that because i would try it i don't know
that's how bad i wouldn't be skinny yeah
that's awesome
now i like face tattoos on the right
people yeah enjoy that
that's a bad idea that's a big that's
aladdin or someone or
so she's got snakes for her it's a
really good tattoo but i really get that
dude
but of course what are you doing sir
what'd you do for money
that you must be still but he must have
a lot of money left
oh wait what's this los angeles
appearance october 2nd
let's give him some pub here click on
that please tell me see it tuned for the
love of god what are you talking about
scrolls on his page on his page see los
angeles yeah yeah listening party should
we go brian
yeah excuse me parties 150
bucks what up guys i'm have a listening
party los angeles
october 2nd come check out my new music
acoustic performance can't wait for that
uh i wonder if it sells out visual
rockstar 150 bucks
go to youtube on him you might like him
brian
really you like his older stuff like his
i want candy stuff
brian likes young stuff let me see this
guy um did you type in music
music video just music 2019.
um come get it you play that one but
then let's play a newer one
oh he just uploaded one 17 hours ago
this now no play that one for brian so
brian knows what he's dealing with
let's hear sooner or later now remember
he's 11 here
he's good he's young now let's go to the
zoo stuff
now you just uploaded something 17 hours
ago scroll down
uh aaron carter anything x kid carter
right there
[Music]
okay that's kind of cool you mad to be
oh man
it's one of the best songs i've ever
heard sometimes rocking side to side is
really cool
and this new aaron carter [ __ ] is fire
okay
it's the longest intro jenna you're the
music man i want you to rate this song
first i'll be honest
so far it's too long hey man
it's just it's a tease wait is this all
it is chin it's probably
what the [ __ ] bro keep going it just
keeps doing this over and over
okay go to another let's just say honey
terrible that beat was
dope for a second really three years ago
with this one oh yeah go to that one
i know this one meaning i've heard it
before
meaning i played every morning i'd like
to hear him acoustic too and have you
judge him chin of course that sounds
good
not a bad looking dude i don't know good
looking kid
she's bigger than he is though that's
i'd probably if i was cast
i'm a fan of hers it's not bad bro it's
got a good voice right or no
i mean yeah it is
drop chin
come on bro watch how i go
ah what are you doing
[Music]
see if there's an acoustic of him all
right that song's not bad enough
i got enough that's not bad i got enough
errand quarter carter all right we'll
move on let me let me get an acoustic
for you how about this
does i want chin to jeffy aaron carter
and this is the acoustic version him and
his brother are talented here we go
let's go here we go one two three four
[Music]
i think it's fake easy song it makes you
miss my body
touch it kiss it squeeze look at it
you made your water fall down
writing original songs and i need you to
do that what would you think of it hey
brian geez i got him i got it coming for
you he put you i got it
what do you think chin by the way i
doubt he wrote that song huh no he def
someone wrote that song i think
if i was auditioning him even back then
for a group i would not
100 but his fault was better his fault
was better
greedy he's a little thin in the voice
this is not that great
you know what you should do is do that
exact thing and put him to shame
true but you don't have the cajones dude
and i want to be i want to let me
harmonize with you
please don't you guys should do it no
you shouldn't because you can actually
sing and better than him
actually i'd love to see your version of
this compared to
my voice is different though but you
could you could do that though
my falsetto is not that high no but i
want to be i want to be in the back
couldn't you do it yourself
couldn't you do a version of that yeah
or lower
i mean should go viral i don't think
it'll go viral
people are gonna start asking for it
watch do people even know this song
did you guys know about the song before
we heard it i did i did not yeah i'm a
fan
his brother can sing things his
brother's great he's brothers nick
his brother can you [ __ ] nick carter
what's his name yeah
all right yeah but this is just tough to
watch no his brother can sing thing
yeah i believe it next one yeah
you should do that though jen i'll think
about it so nick
cannon got onto a podcast and talked to
t.i the other week about how when
he was married to mariah carey there was
some drama between her
and eminem because eminem wrote a track
saying that
he used to date mariah carey on the low
and that he wants her back she then came
out with a song
um why are you so obsessed with me where
she dressed up as eminem stalking her
and he didn't like that so he made a
diss track with her moaning in the back
and eminem did yes and
uh this was around the time when nick
cannon just married mariah carey so he
said that he was calling
agents and reps to see where he was
because he wanted to
find him and essentially like talk it
out or fight him
jesus that's him going out on the
t.i has a podcast podcasting
ever how much money i have doing
podcasting
uh he put i wrote this long ass letter
pretty much saying i respect you as an
artist i'm actually a fan i think you're
one of the best to ever do it
but from man-to-man you talking out of
pocket to my wife
you've got to be held accountable for
that so i need to see you face to face
i was ready for whatever i went looking
for him because you've done
you done disrespecting my wife i need to
show you
my wife i'm a man number one and then
two he said uh my name i said i know i'm
not going to be
able to out wrap you correct whoop your
head whip your ass
those are the exact words of time cooler
heads prevailed at least he sees what's
going on
i don't want to fight anymore he's still
in my top five
i'd be pissed too no they're not married
they're not married anymore
well that's cool he's just saying you've
got to be held accountable for what you
say if you say something we're gonna
have to have this conversation like man
that's all i wanted that's cool
i'm gonna cannon fan i like me yeah i
like the good man
you know the the masked singers uh his
show it's his show yeah
created by nikki wow while now you know
that's just
amazing like every time we have school
in the goldbergs it does so well
mass singer crushes everybody for sure
it's like yeah
it was a show in korea so he just we
made it here so
well he didn't really create it not
crazy but he's the he's the showrunner
yeah yeah and then uh while in out you
know
i'm surprised that that that thing still
it's uh staple for him tv that and uh
interesting
ridiculousness that's right those are
their top two top two yeah
wow now it's fun too what else we got
so back in 2017 an argentinian
woman found out that her sex tape with
her lover at that time was leaked by him
and he showed his friends when she found
out she said that it ruined her personal
life her career
and what she ended up doing was she
started to
to have sex with him she blindfolded him
he was a little reluctant at first
to have the blindfold on but she started
giving him
oral and eventually he said that he felt
something odd
and she cut 90 percent of his
penis off she was just sentenced last
week to 13 year
13 years in prison for it yeah
god and that's what that picture is the
blood that's the aftermath
god damn girl damn brenda brenda
that [ __ ] do you have to cut off his
dick oh and i bet that i bet that blood
was just
pouring out of his cockatiel well she
covered his eyes
so it's back on it didn't say he said i
felt like i was going to die i didn't
know she had cut me
i couldn't see anything i tried to get
up i pulled my trousers grabbed my
mobile phone to call an ambulance
wanted to leave she started to insult me
she grabbed my t-shirt my hair she
wouldn't let me leave
oh wow
oh wow jesus christ
she's the lorena babadov where is this
brazil or some [ __ ] god damn
argentine that's how quiet we got we're
like oh dude that's that
pain i think i'm just getting dicks okay
this is cool
called the pinch what was that i felt
the pinch felt the paper that's that's a
sharp knife
oh what else we got all right well it
looks like marinara sauce all over her
bedroom floor
um i don't have it up here but that girl
amber geiger
that cop that went to the wrong floor
whatever so
i was watching her during the trial
there's like more videos that came out
she was crying
saying like she wished she was the one
that got shot you know it's terrible for
her turns out that the text messaging
she did with the you know the sexting
was a couple days later that's why it
was a big thing
so she was sexting with another cop a
couple days after that event happened
so she was like you know like what
you're supposed to do yeah
people were thinking she would be
freaked out that she just killed someone
you know
it's because you don't know what what
that kind of stress caused you to do all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah
i i can't that would that would be where
to be held up in court
yeah it's not it's not it's just yeah
she made a horrific mistake
maybe it sounds like a horrific if you
saw her on the witness stand she looks
like she's completely devastated or she
is
or whatever witness stand of course she
is this kind of stuff can happen
or crazy this other one we talked about
not too long ago
was it last week vernon the
anheuser-busch guy
reporter so a bunch of people came up to
me and said we're like dude
the the fans are rallying around i'm
like you know this canceled culture
so they got this guy cancelled they said
so many people are rallying around good
he's like back he's a good guy what are
we gonna say though okay so
the more i looked into this i guess the
original reporter from the demons
demon iowa reporter or whatever he just
did a story on that guy and i guess it's
protocol for that
that that uh newspaper to do a
background check it's protocol they have
to do it sure
so during the background check he found
this and he took it back to the
newspaper editors and even asked should
we even talk about this i don't know if
we should talk about it he's so beloved
in iowa he's an iowa legend yeah and he
does a lot for charity
yeah the reporter that actually outed
him it was he said that he went back to
the
to the report the uh newspaper or
whatever and then the team told them
that
um we're not sure we're gonna do about
this so the guy that
that did the campaign whatever the
initial guy that
held up the sign he's the one that outed
himself first and then they published
the story
and it wasn't the actual reporter that
wanted that to come out it was a paper
and now they fired the guy that recorded
it
it's like really really messy this this
reporter had his own back yes
but also this reporter like this is my
problem with all this
you're not making the world a better
place by exposing some kid who did
something said something stupid in high
school
you're not making the world uh less
prejudice it's not making
people who are marginalized people of
color better off
there are other things you know so it
sounds like he was like dude i want to
run the story and the paper was like
we're running this
thing uh you're fired yeah
that's that's why this is all about he
didn't want to run no
he was like this this guy's beloved here
like i don't think we should run the
story
sounds like the what paper the gazelle
the demon
iowa republic [ __ ] yeah register the
registration
but they're uh they're a major
corporation so it's like
you can't do anything to them wow so
he's the scapegoat okay
sorry that's a bummer sorry reporter
yeah it's more complicated than we
originally
thought that's yeah that's interesting i
mean it's not that complicated
just but i mean the new the news outlets
of you know the [ __ ]
yeah so i mean if it's your job you have
to go do a background check and you have
to tell them
you found this information for that they
did
yeah but because he's an escape goat
yeah exactly
that's our bat you can't retract it now
what else you got
uh but he did have some pretty bad
tweets really like from this past
this is it right here there's the
reporter or the
the beer guy the initial reporter that
reported on the anheuser-busch guy
he just retweeted some stuff and then uh
saying now that gay marriage is legal
i'm totally going to marry a horse
silly only if you're a fart face stuff
like like how only black people can use
the n-word or gay people can use that
f-word
too many of these there's a few stuff
but i mean yeah
i'm sure a lot of people have dumb
things in their past it's just a lot of
people clumsy humor
yeah that's just bad [ __ ] break all
right
um this is a bad one i don't know much
about this but this is a
soccer player very famous soccer player
and his friend and he posted this
picture
guess who about his buddy and of course
everyone took that as it's
it's pretty bad but they're best friends
but they're very close and then
the guy the black guy actually tweeted
back like oh that's funny whatever yeah
we're just you know joking around i
guess they tease each other all the time
and what happened to the kid but they're
just
an outcry from the public because man
city teammates right man city is the big
soccer team
yeah he's not pregnant but they're
buddies but he's he's not prejudiced no
but but if there's
friends and they're messing around right
but everybody wants everybody in this
culture
wants to be the one to find the racist
because it's it's how they have no
purpose yeah and it's how they
that that's what they're doing just so
you know i win
and you throw somebody else under the
bus even though they're not a racist but
i found one
i found one it's a sick culture yep what
else it's a bad picture though can't
even joke with a friend these days
you're right
um let's just do this
you know when you see a lot of bear
fights on instagram it's kind of just
like
lackluster they just come and growl this
is actually a pretty good one
these two grizzly bears banging for yeah
for a bit they do on the
[ __ ] it's on the highway yep
first they're talking trash they're
talking about my breath smell my breath
oh well that one on the right is way
thicker yeah right guess who which guess
which one won
oh one small one
shut up there goes oh oh oh we got a
fist
oh yeah oh oh does one kill the other
chin
no oh [ __ ] so it's actually a real fight
it's a shame though because you know in
nature you get [ __ ] up you're screwed
yeah so the big one won god you can see
now he's pushing him out like what's up
bro
and then car hits ball no
he realizes he lost and runs away yeah
cuz you only get [ __ ] up more oh sorry
running towards the video [ __ ]
make that noise before i fight and when
i first thinking
when i climb out when you dump the
grizzly dump
i see that too yep is that a chin that's
pretty much it man
all right guys a great monday at [ __ ]
rock monday i want to thank you guys for
tuning in
southern southern california this is
brian callenbach's job i want you guys
good news i'm at the bray improv uh
october 24 25 26
tickets on sale now bringing heat
i'm going to have uh uh sebastian
mascalico bill burr
brendan schaub and joe rogan open for me
so come on
come on down come on down bro come on
down breath
uh i'm in pittsburgh this week thursday
friday saturday pirate
pittsburgh improv
uh then october 17th through the 19th
i'm in
philly philadelphia november dallas salt
lake city
get your tickets now t5k.com and then
the 50 shades of brown tour
tons of dates uh coming up boston
january 11th
that show has 50 tickets left at the
wilbur
uh if we sell those we're on the second
show so get on it boston
that is january 11th before and then i'm
at uh foxwoods in connecticut
january 10th but all the international
dates
all of the uk um belfast sweden
ireland dublin amsterdam glasgow all of
them
uh those are on sale now tfk.com for
all your tickets pittsburgh see you this
week is that it be that's it buddy this
the fire kid
route